ha you did not did I I don't believe you
I don't believe I'm telling you I was so
drunk that a moon the vice president Wow
professional in my defense though I was
undercover as a socialite so technically
I was in character I have to say I am
not quite that drunk yet you know what's
happening right hmm
we're getting drunk together so that's a
roommate milestone oh okay
[Music]
hey something it's been like two weeks
where have you been oh you know just
hanging out with Sahara yeah stop
hogging her seriously stop hugging her
think somebody else is gonna be hogging
her now
maybe why she's seeing someone I think
so because last night I definitely heard
them having sex what's the big deal it's
just now that I know what her sex noises
sound like any time I hear them in real
life I'm not gonna be able to stop
picturing it god I'll never be able to
play tennis with her it's not that big
of a deal I mean you hear everyone's sex
noises at some point you've heard mine
what yes Rose I'm hungry can we have
lunch now yeah I think I'll be able to
regain my appetite once we get our mails
all right Sahara I haven't heard her
leave her room all morning so maybe not
Alaska
no wait back sorrow Oh Sarah damn that's
some rough sex what's up
[Music]
Zoe hey babe it's been a while Wow
[Music]